We're not, we can't have, we can't have a 60 minute episode. I think that was great. I think that that all should be part of this, this episode. Naming. Part three. Welcome to ADSP The Podcast, episode, recorded on January 27th, 2021. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we're going to be wrapping up part three of our three-part series on naming. So let me ask you about this. So one thing we didn't talk about last time that I made a note
我们不能，我们不能有，我们不能做一个60分钟的单集。我觉得那很棒。我觉得这些都应该成为本集的一部分。命名。第三部分。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客，本集录制于2021年1月27日。我是康纳（Connor），今天与我的联合主持人布莱斯（Bryce）一起，我们将总结关于命名的三部分系列的第三部分。所以让我问你这个。所以上一次我们没有谈到的一件事，我记了下来
about was ordering in names. So let me give you a few examples of that. So the first is like noun underbar verb versus verb underbar noun. Like as an example, do you call a function apply underbar policy or policy underbar apply? And are those two even necessarily the same thing? And what really gets me here is I sometimes see codebases that do this inconsistently. Like they have one function in their API that follows the noun underbar verb, like policy underbar apply. And they have some other function that follows the verb underbar noun pattern. And I don't particularly care which of those two you follow, as long as you're consistent. I have a slight preference for phrasing it as something like verb underbar noun, because I like my identifiers and my code to sort of read as like plain English.
关于命名中的顺序。所以我给你举几个这方面的例子。首先是名词下划线动词与动词下划线名词。比如，你把一个函数叫 apply 下划线 policy（应用策略）还是 policy 下划线 apply（策略应用）？这两者甚至必然是同一回事吗？这里真正让我困惑的是，我有时看到代码库在这方面做得很不一致。比如他们在 API 中有一个函数遵循名词下划线动词，像 policy 下划线 apply。而他们又有另一个函数遵循动词下划线名词模式。我其实并不介意你遵循这两者中的哪一个，只要你保持一致就行。我稍微倾向于把它表述为类似于动词下划线名词的形式，因为我喜欢我的标识符和代码读起来有点像平易近人的英语。
So like something like apply policy, like what does it do? It applies the policy. So do you have any thoughts on that? Well, so this is, this is great because this is like completely adjacent to one of the things I wanted to talk about.
所以就像 apply policy 这样的，它做了什么？它应用了策略。那么你对此有什么看法吗？嗯，所以这个，这个太棒了，因为这和我想要讨论的事情之一完全不谋而合。
So to first answer your question, I've never actually thought about this in terms of noun, underscore, verb, verb, underscore, noun. But in thinking how I would just write code, I think if I were to go look back, it's always verb, underscore, noun. Especially because, like, I started my career in a mathematical domain, actual science. So there was a lot of like, calculate underscore reserve, or calculate underscore premium, or determine underscore, you know, insert something. So I think, inevitably, yeah, if I look back, it was it's almost verb underscore noun. But taking a step back, one thing that I thought was great, because I hadn't thought about it at the time, I heard it from Guy Davidson on a CppCast episode, is the idea of naming functions, verbs and nouns separately, based on whether they are modifying or non-modifying functions. So there's a very classic pattern in Java and C++, and I've even seen it in like Herb Sutter's talks
所以首先回答你的问题，我其实从来没有从名词、下划线、动词，动词、下划线、名词的角度去思考过这个问题。但回想我平时是怎么写代码的，我想如果我去回顾一下，它总是动词、下划线、名词。特别是由于，比如说，我的职业生涯是从数学领域开始的，也就是精算学。所以有很多类似 calculate 下划线 reserve（计算准备金），或者 calculate 下划线 premium（计算保费），或者 determine 下划线，你知道的，插入某个东西。所以我想，不可避免地，是的，如果我回顾过去，它几乎都是动词下划线名词。但退一步讲，有一件事我觉得很好，因为当时我没想到这一点，我是从 CppCast 的一期节目中听盖伊·戴维森（Guy Davidson）说的，这个想法就是将函数的动词和名词分开命名，根据它们是修改型函数还是非修改型函数。所以在 Java 和 C++ 中有一个非常经典的模式，我甚至在像赫伯·萨特（Herb Sutter）的演讲中也看到过
where he shows some reflection example of where we're generating methods for you, where you generate these getters and setters. So you have, you know, you have get value and set value. And Guy's point was that you shouldn't ever need to prefix something with get underscore. If you're just retrieving something, you're not modifying. If it's a non-modifying method, just drop the get.
他展示了一些反射的例子，我们在其中为你生成方法，你生成这些 getter 和 setter。所以你有，你知道的，你有 get value 和 set value。盖伊的观点是，你永远不需要用 get 下划线来给某个东西加前缀。如果你只是在检索某东西，你并没有在修改。如果它是一个非修改型方法，直接去掉 get 好了。
And anytime you have a modifying method, you should be using a verb. Aim into that. There's nothing I hate more than seeing a function that starts with get, you know, under bar. It's just like, it's unnecessary symbols. Which was so, so that's like when it comes to verbs and nouns, when you started talking about that, I was like, oh, is Bryce about to make my point for me? So I'm, this is not, it's not, I just adopted, you know,
而任何时候你有修改型方法，你都应该使用动词。完全赞同。没有什么比看到一个以 get 开头的函数更让我讨厌的了，你知道的，下划线。这就像是，这是不必要的符号。所以，当谈到动词和名词时，当你开始谈论这个的时候，我在想，噢，布莱斯是要替我把观点说出来吗？所以我是，这不是，我只是接受了，你知道的，
the first time I heard it was Guy. He probably heard it from someone else, but I really liked that. Don't judge guy like that for all you know guy was the brilliant genius that invented this it's true well we'll give guy credit even if he did uh uh we'll see yeah maybe maybe guy will listen to this we'll we'll add him on twitter and he can tell us if he heard it from someone or he made it up um because i think it's a great rule and i also i think on that guy the record, I am choosing to assume that you made it up and Connor's choosing to assume
我第一次听到它是从盖伊那儿听来的。他可能是从别人那里听来的，但我真的很喜欢这一点。不要那样评价盖伊，据你所知，盖伊可能是发明这个的发明家天才呢。确实，好吧，我们还是会把功劳记在盖伊头上，即使他确实，呃，呃，我们会看，是的，也许，也许盖伊会听这个节目，我们会在推特上 @ 他，他可以告诉我们他是从别人那里听来的还是他自己瞎编的，呃，因为我觉得这是一个很棒的规则，而且我还认为，在此声明，我选择假设是你自己想出来的，而康纳选择假设
that you just took it from somebody else. Sure, sure, we'll stick with that. But on that episode, he actually made another point how you should prefix predicates, which I had never even heard of that term at the time with is and has. Um, and so I think I asked him, you know, uh, can you define predicate? And that's just a function
你是从别人那里抄来的。当然，当然，我们就这样认为吧。但在那期节目中，他实际上提出了另一个观点，即你应该如何为谓词添加前缀，我当时甚至都没听说过这个术语，即使用 is 和 has。嗯，所以我想我问过他，你知道，呃，“你能定义一下什么是谓词吗？”而这其实就是一个函数
that returns a Boolean. Um, and, uh, that whenever you have that, you should prefix it with is and has, because, or I think that's what ended up happening is that I said, what about, what about functions that like is even, Because technically is is a verb. And he said, oh, any function that starts with an is or has is a predicate. And that's an exception. Anyway, so this gets back to sort of the noun versus verb. So you can comment on everything I just said. But I think putting the verb first is like it makes it more clear that the whole thing together is a verb.
它返回一个布尔值。嗯，而且，呃，每当你有这种情况时，你都应该用 is 和 has 给它加前缀，因为，或者我想最后的结果是，我说：“那像 is even 这样的函数呢？因为严格来说 is 是个动词。”他说：“哦，任何以 is 或 has 开头的函数都是谓词。这是一个例外。”不管怎样，这就回到了名词与动词的话题。所以你可以对刚才我所说的一切发表评论。但我认为把动词放在前面就像是让整个组合更清楚地表明它整体是一个动词。
When you're saying, you know, calculate reserve. Really, the key in those two words is calculate. And if it's actually a free function, so it's not like a non-modifying or modifying, like ideally it's a pure function without side effects. And in that case, actually, I don't know what I prefer. Do I prefer calculate reserve or reserve? Because if you call it reserve, you just pass it the arguments. I don't know. So that question about the predicate or that Mark does about the predicate function is actually interesting.
当你在说，你知道，calculate reserve（计算准备金）。实际上这两个词的关键在于 calculate（计算）。如果它实际上是一个自由函数，所以它不像非修改型或修改型那样，理想情况下它是一个没有副作用的纯函数。在这种情况下，实际上，我不知道我更喜欢哪种。我更喜欢 calculate reserve 还是 reserve？因为如果你叫它 reserve，你只需把参数传给它。我不知道。所以关于那个谓词的问题，或者马克对谓词函数所做的那个标记，其实很有意思。
And that's one of the few patterns that's actually in the proposed recommendations for standard library design guidelines. But as I mentioned a little earlier, one of the conclusions we came to when considering C++ library design guidelines in the C++ library design group last week was we want to try to avoid decorating names whenever it's not necessary. And by decorating names, I mean adding prefixes or suffixes just because a function or an identifier is some class of thing, sort of similar to the Hungarian naming convention where you embed the type of the thing into the name. But one of the ones that we'd actually suggested did make sense was, you know, to have the is under bar for predicates. One of the examples that somebody pointed out was the empty method on a lot of the standard library containers. It's kind of
这也是标准库设计指南的提议推荐中实际存在的少数几个模式之一。但正如我刚才稍早提到的，上周我们在 C++ 库设计小组中讨论 C++ 库设计指南时得出的结论之一是：每当不必要时，我们都想尽量避免装饰名称。而我所说的装饰名称，是指仅仅因为某个函数或标识符属于某种类型的事务就添加前缀或后缀，这有点类似于匈牙利命名法，即把事物的类型嵌入到名称中。但我们实际上建议确实有意义的其中一个，你知道的，就是为谓词加上 is 下划线。有人指出其中一个例子是许多标准库容器上的 empty 方法。这有点
ambiguous whether calling vector.empty empties the contents of the container or tells you whether it's empty or not. And the standard library is actually like a little bit inconsistent here. So as an example of that, C++'s std future has a valid method. Now that one's pretty unambiguous, you know, that that tells you whether it's valid or not, unlike empty, which is a bit more ambiguous. But the concurrency TS proposes some additions to std future. And one of those additions is an is ready function.
含糊不清，调用 vector.empty 究竟是清空容器的内容，还是告诉你它是否为空。而标准库在这里实际上有点不一致。作为其中的一个例子，C++ 的 std::future 有一个 valid 方法。现在那个相当明确，你知道的，那会告诉你它是有效的还是无效的，不像 empty 那样有点含糊不清。但并发 TS 提议对 std::future 进行一些添加。其中一个添加就是 is_ready 函数。
And I just find it amusing that, you know, I could understand inconsistency between different classes, but it really tickles me that there's a proposed inconsistency within this same class, that we would have is ready, which would be one predicate, and valid, which would be another. And I am inclined to say the world would have been better if std vector had called it is empty. So maybe that's one of those rare cases where the decoration is really truly useful. So I thought that it was a widely acknowledged fact that empty was a mistake and that going forward we were always supposed to use is empty. I can't find it right now, but I know that there's two examples in the standard that have actually started using is empty. One of them is std file system.
我只觉得好笑，你知道的，我可以理解不同类之间的不一致，但让我感到开心的是，在同一个类中提议存在不一致，我们将拥有 is_ready（作为一个谓词），以及 valid（作为另一个谓词）。我倾向于认为，如果 std::vector 当初把它叫做 is_empty，这个世界会变得更好。所以也许这就是那种装饰确实非常有用的小数几个罕见案例之一。所以我原以为这是一个广泛认可的事实，即 empty 是一个错误，并且展望未来，我们应该始终使用 is_empty。我现在找不到了，但我知道标准中有两个例子实际上已经开始使用 is_empty 了。其中一个是 std::filesystem。
The other one I can't find right now. You're absolutely right that that is the policy going forward, and that's what we were discussing last week was codifying it into an actual policy document. What was interesting, though, is that the other day I was code reviewing someone's code, and we have, I think it's in the QDF repositories. It's the open source library I work on. We have a device span and it had an empty method. And whenever I see that, I comment,
另一个我现在找不到了。你完全说得对，这就是未来的政策，而这正是我们上周讨论的将其编纂成实际政策文档的内容。不过，有趣的是，前几天我在对别人的代码进行代码审查，我们有，我想它在 QDF 仓库中。这是我参与开发的开源库。我们有一个 device_span，它有一个 empty 方法。每当我看到这个，我就会评论：
oh, let's prefer is empty. And I have some links somewhere where I link to, you know, this is a widely regarded mistake and that going forward we should use is empty. And I think it was- Although if we're going to do that, we should probably, and that going forward, we should use is empty. And I think if we're going to do that, we should probably all of the C++ standard library things that currently have an empty, we'd probably need to give them an additional is empty, so that people can consistently just use is empty, you know, it's a pain if you have to remember hmm does this thing have an
哦，我们更倾向于使用 is_empty。我在某处有一些链接，我链接到，你知道的，这是一个被广泛认为的错误，展望未来我们应该使用 is_empty。我想那是——尽管如果我们要这样做，我们可能应该，并且展望未来，我们应该使用 is_empty。我想如果我们要这样做，我们可能应该把 C++ 标准库中所有目前带有 empty 的东西，我们可能需要给它们提供一个额外的 is_empty，以便人们可以始终如一地只使用 is_empty，你知道的，如果你必须记住，嗯，这个东西有一个
empty or an is empty and then it becomes even more of a pain in generic code uh that's true um so yeah it would be nice to get those um but where i was going with that is that the the person i think it was vukasan i hope he doesn't mind me shouting out his name his response was oh we're keeping it consistent with stood span or yeah and was like, wait, what? Span added empty? I thought we were not doing that anymore. Well, span probably did it for the reason I just mentioned, which is span probably called it empty and not is empty
empty 还是 is_empty，这会是一件很痛苦的事，然后在泛型代码中这就变得更加痛苦了。嗯，确实，所以，能够拥有这些会很不错；但我刚才要说到的是，那个人，我想是武卡山（Vukasan），我希望他不介意我大声说出他的名字，他的回应是：“哦，我们保持与 std::span 的一致性”或者“哦，等等，什么？span 加上了 empty？我以为我们不再那样做了。”好吧，span 这样做可能出于我刚才提到的原因，即 span 可能叫它 empty 而不是 is_empty
because for consistency with the existing things, yeah. See, this is the problem with consistency is that sometimes you have to, like, some, I I always say and this is sort of like Bryce's law. I'd I'd rather be consistently wrong than inconsistent. That that the idea that that, you know,, like why is spans empty? Why does span have empty and not is empty? Because it would rather be consistently wrong. Like, I'm not going to have any flexibility of thought on my opinions on matters. I'd rather just stick to my guns and be wrong than eventually be inconsistent and change my mind. That sounds like an awful law. I am happy with my law as stated.
是因为为了与现有的东西保持一致，对吧。看，这就是一致性的问题所在，有时你必须，像，我总是说——这有点像是布莱斯的定律——我宁愿一直错得一致，也不愿不一致。那种认为，你知道的，比如为什么 span 的是 empty？为什么 span 有 empty 而没有 is_empty？因为它宁愿错得一致。就像，对于我在某些事情上的观点，我不会有任何思维上的灵活性。我宁愿固执己见并出错，也不愿最终变得不一致并改变主意。这听起来像是一个可怕的定律。我对表述出来的这个定律很满意。
Are you sure? I'm going to give you a couple episodes to think about whether you want this to be your law. I will think about that. So I have another story, which I'll give a shout out to my coworker, John Bichon, who was actually my coworker at NVIDIA and also my coworker at Lawrence Berkeley National Lab, where we used to work. And we were both at Lawrence Berkeley. He was working on this asynchronous runtime system. And whenever you have such a system, I worked on one myself called HPX. You tend to have some set of functions that are asynchronous and that have some async decorator on them. And in the code bases I had worked with, the async always came on them. And in the codebases I had worked with, the async always came at the front.
你确定吗？我要给你几个单集的时间去考虑你是否希望这成为你的定律。我会考虑的。所以我还有另一个故事，我要顺便感谢我的同事约翰·比雄（John Bichon），他实际上是我在英伟达（Nvidia）时的同事，也是我在劳伦斯伯克利国家实验室（Lawrence Berkeley National Lab）时的同事，我们以前在那里工作过。我们当时都在劳伦斯伯克利。他当时在开发这个异步运行时系统。每当你拥有这样一个系统时，我自己也开发过一个叫 HPX 的系统。你往往会有一组异步的函数，并且它们上面带有某个 async 装饰器。在我合作过的代码库中，async 总是写在它们前面。在我合作过的代码库中，async 总是写在它们前面。
So you'd have async underscore reduce or async underscore transform, et cetera. But in John's codebase, if I recall correctly, he would call it reduce underscore async, transform underscore async. And I one time asked him, hey, why do you put it at the end, not the start? And he told me, well, he thinks of it sort of like That he wanted the most specific thing to be first. So what's the most specific thing of an asynchronous reduction algorithm? Well, it's of the family of reduction algorithms. That's more fundamental than it being a member of the family of things
所以你会有 async 下划线 reduce 或者 async 下划线 transform 等等。但在约翰的代码库中，如果我没记错的话，他会把它叫做 reduce 下划线 async、transform 下划线 async。我曾经问过他：“嘿，你为什么把它放在末尾，而不是开头？”他告诉我，好吧，他觉得这有点像，他希望最具体的东西排在最前面。那么一个异步规约算法中最具体的东西是什么？嗯，它是规约算法家族的一部分。这比它属于异步事物家族的成员更为根本。
that are asynchronous. So he sort of made an argument that the ordering of things in the name said something about sort of the grouping or the categorization of those things. And I've also heard this claim made for things like code completion, that if you call it async underscore reduce and async underscore transform, then when you type async underscore, you're going to get almost everything in your library. Whereas if you do it the other way around, then if you type reduce, you'll get auto-completion for reduce just the synchronous version and reduce underscore async and whatever other functions you have that are some form of reduction. And so I thought that was a very interesting notion that I had namespaces, but even just within the identifier itself.
所以他提出了一种论证，即名称中事物的顺序说明了这些事物的分组或分类。我也听到过有人对代码补全之类的事情提出这种说法，即如果你把它叫做 async 下划线 reduce 和 async 下划线 transform，那么当你键入 async 下划线 时，你会得到你库中的几乎所有东西。而如果你反过来做，那么当你键入 reduce 时，你将获得仅限同步版本的 reduce 以及 reduce 下划线 async 和你拥有的任何其他作为某种形式的规约的函数的自动补全。所以我认为这是一个非常有趣的观点，我有命名空间，甚至仅在标识符本身内部也是如此。
Yeah, no, I've actually spent a lot of time thinking about that because there are examples where it's an amazing design for exact for that exact reason that you end up with like a list of algorithms that are alphabetically sorted and then you see you know zip underscore zip underscore zip underscore and you you're clearly like oh okay these are these are all doing roughly the same thing however you can go too far with it in some cases so like in ruby there is a collection of algorithms. I just looked it up. So they each start with each underscore, each cons, each entry, each slice, each with index, and each with object. And I don't know what all these do, but if I were to ask you, what do you think each underscore cons does? Like, do you think you could guess?
是的，不，我实际上花了很多时间去思考这个问题，因为有些例子它的设计非常绝妙，正是出于你刚才提到的那个原因，你最终得到了一份按字母顺序排序的算法列表，然后你会看到，你知道的，zip 下划线、zip 下划线、zip 下划线，并且你清楚地意识到：“哦，好吧，这些大致都在做同一件事。”然而，在某些情况下，你可能会做得过头；比如在 Ruby 中，有一个算法集合。我刚刚查了一下。所以它们每个都以 each 下划线开头：each 下划线 cons、each 下划线 entry、each 下划线 slice、each 下划线 with 下划线 index 和 each 下划线 with 下划线 object。我不知道所有这些是做什么用的，但如果我问你：“你认为 each 下划线 cons 是做什么用的？”比如，你觉得你能猜到吗？
And our listeners can play along if you want and and the point that i'm about to make here is that yes they've they've family familyized these you know they put them in a group but they've completely in my opinion obfuscated like what these do and like the same named algorithms in other languages are completely different interesting in fact i'll give you a I'll give you a hint about each cons. The cons is a reference to an old language. Yes. So it's like a reference to Lisp, right? Like to the operation where it takes the tail of a list? Well, cons is basically your procedure that creates a pair. So in Lisp, your linked list is just a bunch of conses.
如果你愿意的话，我们的听众也可以一起猜，我要在这里提出的观点是，是的，它们把这些归为了一类，它们把它们放在了一个组里，但在我看来，它们完全把这些东西的作用给搞模糊了，就像其他语言中同名的算法完全不同一样。有趣的是，事实上，我给你关于 each 下划线 cons 的一个提示。cons 是对一种旧语言的引用。是的。所以这就像是对 Lisp 的引用，对吧？就像对获取列表尾部的那个操作的引用？嗯，cons 基本上是创建序对的程序。所以在 Lisp 中，你的链表只是一堆 cons。
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah. But so I believe, I can double click just to make sure that I'm not wrong, that each cons, you pass it an integer, and it gives you the sliding window of of the length of that so like each cons two will give you adjacent pairs each cons three will give you a sliding window of length three where the step is one and so so this yeah this in most languages is called uh sliding or windows or windowed you know rust i think just added a couple different versions of this in their 1.48 or whatever the version that they're on. But yeah, so I completely agree that there are times where
哦，是的，是的，是的。但所以，我相信，我可以仔细确认一下以确保我没有弄错，对于 each 下划线 cons，你传给它一个整数，它会给你该长度的滑动窗口。所以像 each 下划线 cons 2 会给你相邻的序对，each 下划线 cons 3 会给你一个长度为 3、步长为 1 的滑动窗口。所以，是的，在大多数语言中这被称为滑动（sliding）或窗口（windows）或带窗口的（windowed），你知道的，我想 Rust 刚刚在其 1.48 版本或者它们当前所在的那个版本中添加了几个不同版本的这个功能。但是，是的，所以我完全同意，有时
prefixing everything with the same prefix is a really good way to have people explore the language and discover, oh, look, there's a very similar algorithm I could use. In other cases like this, I think each with index isn't bad. I think that's just basically, it's called... Yeah, that makes more sense. It's called different things in different languages. The most common name is enumerate from Python, where you just bundle each element with an index.
用相同的前缀给所有东西加前缀，是让人们探索语言并发现“哦，看，有一个我可以使用的非常相似的算法”的好方法。在其他情况下，像这样，我认为 each 下划线 with 下划线 index 并不坏。我认为那基本上就是，它被称为……是的，这更有意义。它在不同的语言中被称为不同的名字。最常见的名字是 Python 中的 enumerate（枚举），你只需将每个元素与一个索引打包在一起。
But yeah, in this case, I think they went too far. And it's really unfortunate because Crystal, which is actually a language I think I first heard about from you, it's basically Ruby statically typed, although I think Ruby actually just got static typing in like Ruby something point something. It's, yeah. Thank you for that very informative comment.
但是，是的，在这种情况下，我认为他们走得太远了。这真的很不幸，因为 Crystal —— 这实际上是我认为我第一次从你那里听说的语言 —— 它基本上就是静态类型的 Ruby，尽管我认为 Ruby 实际上刚刚在某个版本的 Ruby 中加入了静态类型。它，是的。谢谢你提供这个非常有信息量的评论。
Ruby static typing. 3.0, I'll guess. The state of Ruby 3 typing. I'll find out if it's been added and added to the show notes. I could be mixing up Scala 3 and Ruby 3. Because Scala 3, otherwise known as Dottie, is like... See, folks, this is why you shouldn't learn... This is why you should have learned only a few terms in there.
Ruby 的静态类型。3.0，我猜。Ruby 3 类型的现状。我会查一下它是否已被添加并将其添加到节目笔记中。我可能是把 Scala 3 和 Ruby 3 搞混了。因为 Scala 3，也就是大家所知道的 Dottie，就像是……看，各位，这就是为什么你不应该学习……这就是为什么你本该只在那里学几个术语的原因。
This is not a lot. Because then you don't get them mixed up. Touche. Fair point. Anyways, what was my point here? All right, Crystal is statically typed, supposed to have the performance of C version of Ruby. But they basically just like verbatim took all the algorithm names from Ruby. Whereas Elixir, which is basically like Ruby plus Erlang, they looked at all the algorithms, took the good ones, and then renamed the bad ones.
这样就不会把它们搞混了。说得好。有道理。不管怎样，我刚才的重点是什么？好吧，Crystal 是静态类型的，据说拥有 C 语言版本的 Ruby 的性能。但它们基本上就是一字不差地采用了 Ruby 的所有算法名称。而 Elixir —— 它基本上就像 Ruby 加上 Erlang —— 它们审视了所有的算法，取其精华，然后把不好的名字重新命名了。
So they didn't take any of the each underscore methods. They renamed them to like chunk and better names, which I think is the better learn from, learn from languages, mistakes, copy what they did right. And then, you know, iterate. Yeah. What do you, what do you think about, uh, about naming styles? Well, so is this, is this like snake case versus Pascal case versus case? Well, so, um, well, well I'll answer that in a sec. Cause I don't know. Yeah. Well, kebab case is adjacent to, um, yeah. So there's, well, okay, let's, let's answer that in a sec. What is kebab case? I don't know what kebab case is. Yeah, well, kebab case is adjacent to... Yeah, so there's... Okay, let's answer this question. So we've got snake case, pascal, camel, and kebab case are like the four main ones.
所以它们没有采用任何 each 下划线方法。它们把它们重命名成了诸如 chunk 之类的更好的名字，我认为这才是更好的做法：从语言的错误中吸取教训，复制他们做对的事情，然后，你知道的，迭代。是的。你对，你对命名风格有什么看法？嗯，所以，这是蛇形命名法（snake case）对帕斯卡命名法（Pascal case）对……什么命名法？嗯，所以，嗯，嗯，我等会儿回答那个问题。因为我不知道。是的。好吧，串面盒命名法（kebab case）与……是的。所以有，好吧，让我们等会儿回答那个问题。什么是串面盒命名法？我不知道什么是串面盒命名法。是的，好吧，串面盒命名法类似于……是的，所以有……好吧，让我们回答这个问题。所以我们有蛇形命名法、帕斯卡命名法、驼峰命名法（camel case）和串面盒命名法，这是主要的四种。
There's a couple other variants, but I think those are the four main ones. I think most people have heard of snake case. It's the underscores in between words. Pascal case, the start of each word is capitalized. Camel case is pascal case, but of each word is capitalized camel case is pascal case but the first word is lowercase and kebab case for any lispers out there um they'll know what um kebab case is it's where you hyphenate the the words uh i actually like kebab kebab case quite a bit although it does not work in a number of languages uh it definitely doesn't work in a number of languages but i i think snake case
还有其他一些变体，但我认为这四种是主要的。我想大多数人都听说过蛇形命名法。它就是在单词之间加上下划线。帕斯卡命名法，每个单词的首字母都大写。驼峰命名法就是帕斯卡命名法，但每个单词的首字母都大写，驼峰命名法就是帕斯卡命名法，但第一个单词是小写的，至于串面盒命名法，对于任何使用 Lisp 的人来说，嗯，他们会知道什么是串面盒命名法，就是你把单词用连字符连起来。我其实相当喜欢串面盒命名法，尽管它在许多语言中无法使用。它确实在许多语言中无法使用，但我认为蛇形命名法
is my my preferred my my preference i really strongly dislike camel case i just think it's like super unreadable and it's just like it is jarring to me for the first word to not be capitalized i and i just i want to understand why why should it why should the first word not be capitalized but the rest of them should be it's just like pascal case i can i can i'm i can be okay with because like it's consistently capitalized at the first letter of each word like that's okay but but no i'm not okay with not okay with camel case i do not share i mean i'm i'm surprised actually that you have such uh not strong feelings about formatting you know you can do without but then for for that first letter in camel case uh that's where you draw the line
是我更偏爱的、我的首选。我非常讨厌驼峰命名法，我只是觉得它超级难读，而且它让我感到刺耳的是第一个单词竟然不大写。我，我只是想了解为什么，为什么第一个单词不应该大写，而其余的单词却应该大写？这就好比帕斯卡命名法，我可以，我能接受，因为每个单词的首字母都一致大写，那没问题。但是不，我不能接受驼峰命名法。我并不认同——我的意思是，我其实很惊讶你对格式化有这么强烈的看法，你可以不用，但对于驼峰命名法中的那个首字母——那就是你的底线所在。
either capitalize or don't capitalize um yeah is there is there is there a style where you don't use underscores but you don't capitalize anything where you just mush everything together does that have a name uh all lowercase i don't know we'll let we'll let our listeners if that's a thing tweet at us and we'll mention it what do you say say? So in C++20, in the C++ standard for many years, the names for things that were the moral equivalent of concepts, we didn't have concepts in the language, but we had names for these sets of requirements. Those names were always, they used Pascal case, which was nice because it made them distinct from the standard library identifiers, which were all used snake case. And when we added concepts, we were originally going to add
要么大写，要么不大写。是的，有没有这样一种风格，你不用下划线，也不大写任何东西，你只是把所有东西都挤在一起，这有名字吗？嗯，全部小写。我不知道，我们会让听众，如果这是个东西的话，在推特上 @ 我们，然后我们会提到它。你觉得呢？所以在 C++20 中，在 C++ 标准中很多年里，那些在道德上等同于概念的事物的名称，我们在语言中没有概念，但我们有这些需求集合的名称。这些名称始终，它们使用的是帕斯卡命名法，这很好，因为这使它们与标准库标识符区分开来，标准库标识符全都使用蛇形命名法。而当我们添加概念时，我们原本打算添加
the named concepts in the standard library as Pascal case, following the precedent of the named requirements that had been in C++ for many years, like copy constructible or random access iterator. Those names would have been spelled in Pascal case. But then a fairly late decision was made to make those concept names be snake case, which has led, I think, to some unfortunate ambiguities. So for example, std colon colon iterator is the name of a concrete type from like C++ 03 or C++ 11, whereas std colon colon random access iterator is the name of a concept. Whereas
标准库中的命名概念作为帕斯卡命名法，遵循 C++ 中存在多年的命名要求的先例，比如 copy_constructible（可复制构造）或 random_access_iterator（随机访问迭代器）。这些名称原本会以帕斯卡命名法拼写。但随后做出了一项相当晚期的决定，即让这些概念名称采用蛇形命名法，我认为这导致了一些不幸的歧义。因此，例如 std::iterator 是来自 C++03 或 C++11 的具体类型的名称，而 std::random_access_iterator 是概念的名称。然而
with the Pascal casing, you had this, it was very visually clear when something was a concept versus a type because the concepts were in Pascal case and the concrete types were in snake case. But we decided we didn't like that. And I personally think it was a mistake. I don't know, what do you think about it? Do you think it's confusing that the concepts use the same naming pattern or the same naming style as types? I did say earlier in this discussion that, you know, I'm not a fan of, you know, these decorator type patterns where you have a prefix or a suffix or a particular style for things. But I guess in this case, I felt it would have been a good idea to have concepts be visually distinct from types
使用帕斯卡命名法，你会有这样一种情况，当某物是概念与类型时，它在视觉上非常清晰，因为概念采用帕斯卡命名法，而具体类型采用蛇形命名法。但我们决定不喜欢这样。我个人认为这是一个错误。我不知道，你对此怎么看？你觉得概念使用与类型相同的命名模式或相同的命名风格会令人困惑吗？我在这场讨论的早些时候确实说过，你知道的，我不是那种装饰类型模式的粉丝，即你为事物拥有前缀、后缀或特定风格。但我想在这种情况下，我觉得在标准中，在 C++ 标准库中，让概念在视觉上与类型区别开来是一个好主意。
in the standard, in the C++ standard library. Yeah, I mean, I feel like that paper and that decision got made on either the first or the second committee meeting that i went to and um i didn't spend most of my time in luge um but i was i did sit in on a couple of the discussions i did not have anywhere as near as a strong opinion as the people in the room um uh think the biggest argument, if I recall, against mixing them was like, this was breaking precedence for the first time ever. And it's-
是的，我的意思是，我觉得那篇论文和那个决定是在我参加的第一场或第二场委员会会议上做出的，而且我并没有把大部分时间花在 luge 上，但我确实旁听了几场讨论。我的观点远没有屋里的那些人那么强烈。呃，我想如果我没记错的话，反对混合它们的最大论点是：这有史以来第一次打破了先例。而且它是——
Although, but you could argue it was like, it was going to break precedence either way because it broke the precedence of the existing naming pattern. There was a thing that was referenced in the standard called random access iterator in Pascal case. It wasn't a programmatic concept because those didn't exist yet.
尽管如此，但你可以辩称，无论如何它都会打破先例，因为它打破了现有命名模式的先例。标准中曾有一个名为 random_access_iterator 的事物，采用帕斯卡命名法。它不是一个编程式概念，因为那些东西当时还不存在。
But the name of it now is inconsistent with what we used to refer to this set of requirements. So I think, and I wasn't in the room at the time of this discussion because I was chairing a different room. But if I had't in the room at the time of this discussion because I was chairing a different room, but if I had been in the room, I would have made the argument that there was going to be an inconsistency either way. And we should have gone with the one that was going to be less ambiguous and that was going to follow what the existing name of these things
但它现在的名称与我们过去用来指代这组要求的名称不一致。所以我想，而且当时讨论时我不在屋里，因为我在主持另一个房间。但是如果我当时在讨论时如果在屋里，因为我在主持另一个房间，但如果我当时在屋里，我会提出这样的论点：无论哪种方式都会产生不一致性。我们应该选择那种歧义更少、并且能够顺应这些东西现有名称的方案。
was. Well, so although what you say is true, I think the argument was coming from trainers or people whose primary occupation and are very exposed to teaching C++. And you mentioned that's the way it is in the standard. I don't think the majority of C++ developers are working their way through the standard. And then you can make the argument, well, it's not just the standard. It's also an EOP, elements of programming. I don't think it was just through the standard. And then you can make the argument, well, it's not just the standard. It's also an EOP, elements of programming. I don't think it was just in the standard. If you go and look on CPP reference uses it, I think there's a lot of code that,
好吧，尽管你所说的是真的，但我认为这个论点来自培训师或那些以教授 C++ 为主要职业且大量接触 C++ 的人。你提到标准中就是这样的。我不认为大多数 C++ 开发人员在通读标准。然后你可以辩称，嗯，这不仅仅是标准。这也是 EOP，程序设计元素（Elements of Programming）。我不认为这仅仅在标准中。如果你去看看 CPP reference 上也在使用它，我认为有很多代码，
there's a lot of pre-C++20 code that referred to some of the core concepts from the standard using the Pascal case naming that the standard uses. I'm sure there's a lot of codes out there that refer to this type is copy constructible Pascal case. So, you know, yes, you can make all those arguments, but I think the argument, and so this is the thing is I'm doing a poor job because I'm trying to make someone else's argument for them. But I think their point was like, this is it's different. And this is going to be one more thing that I have to teach that like, people are going to are, you know, whether it's students, or whether it's professionals that are, you know, getting training,
有很多 C++20 之前的代码使用标准中使用的帕斯卡命名法来指代标准中的一些核心概念。我确信有很多代码都在引用这种类型是 copy_constructible（帕斯卡命名法）。所以，你知道的，是的，你可以提出所有这些论点，但我想这个论点——这就是问题所在，我做得不好，因为我试图替别人提出他们的论点。但我想他们的观点是，这很不一样。这将是我必须教授的又一件事，人们会，你知道的，无论是学生，还是正在接受培训的专业人士，
or just learning the language for the first time, they're going to ask, you know, oh, why is this different? And it's a short answer. It a concept but i think from the educator's point of view like if they're if there's one thing that they don't need to teach or like they don't need to add to a bullet list of points of like you know insert why is this different that's preferable but now they do have to teach people that stood colon colon iterator isn't the name of the of a concept even though stood colon colon random access iterator is the name of a concept, even though std colon colon random access iterator is the name of a concept. And a bunch of other little cases like that. Like, I don't remember what it was for.
或者只是第一次学习这门语言，他们会问，你知道的，“哦，为什么这不一样？”答案很短。它是一个概念。但我认为从教育者的角度来看，如果有一件事是他们不需要教的，或者他们不需要加到诸如“插入为什么这不一样”的要点列表中去的，那是更可取的。但现在他们确实必须教人们 std::iterator 不是一个概念的名称，尽管 std::random_access_iterator 是一个概念的名称，尽管 std::random_access_iterator 是一个概念的名称。以及许多其他诸如此类的小情况。比如，我不记得它是为了什么了。
There was another one around Boolean that was very odd. Yeah. Anyway, so we should get someone on that voted for it, and then you can debate them. But yeah, we have to go. But the last thing I want to say before we wrap this episode up is that the same way that LISPs have a very sort of unique kebab style for some of the LISP dialects, I actually think that LISPs have a feature that I wish a lot of other programming languages had when it comes to the naming of predicates do you know how uh you denotate a predicate function in a lisp or in most uh i don't you use a question mark um which i actually really really like because instead of having to say is empty or has feature, which don't share the same prefix,
还有一个关于布尔值的非常奇怪。是的。无论如何，我们应该找一个投票赞成它的人来上节目，然后你可以和他们辩论。但是，是的，我们得走了。但在我们结束本集之前，我想说的最后一件事是，就像 LISP 拥有某种非常独特的、针对某些 LISP 方言的串面盒风格一样，我实际上认为 LISP 拥有一个功能，当涉及谓词命名时，我希望许多其他编程语言也能拥有它。你知道你如何在 LISP 或大多数语言中表示一个谓词函数吗？我不造。你使用一个问号。我其实真的非常非常喜欢这个，因为不必说 is_empty 或 has_feature（它们不共享相同的前缀），
all of the predicates end in a question mark. So instead of is empty, it's just empty question mark. And then if you have, what's another one? Is even. So yeah, even and positive are not like is even or is positive. It's just even question mark, positive question mark. And I think that's super, super nice because there is actually some cases where is and has, you know, the is underscore and has underscore aren't the right prefixes. And then you sort of have to come up
所有的谓词都以问号结尾。所以与其说是 is_empty，不如干脆就是 empty 问号。如果你有，另一个是什么？is_even。所以，是的，even 和 positive 不像 is_even 或 is_positive。它就是 even 问号、positive 问号。我认为这超级超级好，因为确实有些情况下 is 和 has，你知道的，is 下划线和 has 下划线并不是正确的前缀。然后你不得不去想
with some awkward prefix that doesn't really work great. But if you can just add a question mark on the end, it becomes immediately clear, oh, this is just a predicate and I can use something simple. That's interesting. Yeah. I think that it would be interesting to see what a language like C++ would have looked like if we could have had a wider set of characters and identifiers. Like if we could have had question marks and identifiers or exclamation points and identifiers, a wider set of characters and identifiers. Like if we could have had question marks and identifiers or exclamation points and identifiers, what styles would that have led to?
某个其实效果不太好的尴尬前缀。但如果你能直接在末尾加上一个问号，它就会立刻变得清晰明了：哦，这只是一个谓词，我可以使用一些简单明了的东西。这很有趣。是的。我认为，如果我们能拥有更广泛的字符和标识符集，像 C++ 这样的语言会是什么样子，这会很有趣。比如，如果我们能在标识符中拥有问号或感叹号，更广泛的字符和标识符集。如果我们能在标识符中拥有问号或感叹号，那会带来什么样的风格呢？
Because I know languages that do allow question marks or exclamation points and identifiers, you know, those are often used to convey, to denote certain types of functions, etc. Like, I generally think that languages benefit greatly from having as many characters in the identifier set as possible without, of course, restricting, you know, what you have available as operators, etc. Yeah, there's like Smalltalk is a language that you can define binary operations as any combination of like a set of like 20 different ASCII characters. So you can come up with some really, really cool things that yeah, you can't you can't do anything. You're limited by the set of what binary operators are overloadable in C++, which we do have a bunch, but you can't just like
因为我知道那些允许在标识符中使用问号或感叹号的语言，你知道的，它们经常被用来传达、表示特定类型的函数等。像，我通常认为语言从拥有尽可能多的标识符集字符中受益匪浅，当然前提是不能限制，你知道的，作为运算符等可用字符。是的，就像 Smalltalk 是一种你可以将二元运算定义为诸如大约 20 种不同 ASCII 字符集的任意组合的语言。所以你可以想出一些非常非常酷的东西，是的，你不能，你什么也做不了。你受限于 C++ 中可重载的二元运算符集的范围，虽然我们确实有很多，但你不能只是凭空创造一个以前不存在的运算符，而在其他语言中你可以。是的，我总是嫉妒那些能够发明诸如此类运算符的语言。我认为这是一个非常强大功能。这也是我经常希望在像 C++ 这样的语言中也能拥有的功能。其实 Julia，我刚了解到你基本上可以定义你想要的任何 unicode 运算符，因为它是一门科学语言，所以很多诸如特定领域应用想要拥有像逻辑与（即倒 V 形）或逻辑或之类的东西。使用许多 C++ 编译器，你可以在函数名中侥幸使用 Unicode，
create one out of thin air that doesn't exist before, whereas in other languages you can. Yeah, I'm always jealous of languages that can invent, you know, operators like that. I think it's a very powerful feature. It's one that I often wish I had access to in a language like C++. Julia, actually, I just learned you basically can define like any unicode operator that you want because it's a scientific language and so a lot of like uh domain specific applications they want to have like a logical and that's you know the upside down v and a logical or with a with a lot of c plus plus uh uh compilers you can get away with using Unicode in your function names,
不是用于运算符，而是用于函数名。所以你可以用这种方法搞出一些小花招。如果你在 Twitter 上关注了 JFBastion，你大概对这个很熟悉。是的。我也见过，我想是在一个 Meeting C++ 的测验中，我看到它只是笑脸表情符号。那是，你知道的，这是什么输出？是的，我也记得那个。我们当时一起在那儿。
not for operators, but in function names. And so there are some shenanigans you can get away with there. If you follow JFBastion on Twitter, you're probably familiar with this. Yeah. I've also, I think it was in a meeting C++ quiz, I saw it was just smiley face emojis. It was, you know, what is this output? Yeah, I remember that too. That was, we were there together.
那是 2019 年。天哪，你还记得那个？你还记得那个？那是疯狂的一个月。我们在路上待了大约六周。那是我们去……你在路上的时间比我还长。是的，那是……我怀念那些日子。
That was 2019. Man, you remember that? You remember that? That was a crazy month. We were on the road for like six weeks. That was when we went to... You were on the road longer than I was. Yeah, that was... I miss those days.
我怀念那些日子。我有多久没坐过飞机了？现在差不多有 11 个月或 12 个月了。是的，肯定有，是的，因为去年去布拉格我们就是坐飞机的。哦，天哪，我想念它。我想念它。我想念它。没关系。疫苗。
I miss those days. How long has it been since I've been on a plane? It's almost, I think, 11 months or 12 months now. Yeah, it's got to be, yeah, because it would have been Prague last year that we went on a plane. Oh, man, I miss it. I miss it. I miss it. It's all right. The vaccine.
我的伴侣昨天刚打了第二针疫苗。哦，太棒了。我祖父和我爸爸这周正在打第二剂。我祖母终于打了她的疫苗。所以现在我直系亲属中所有 80 岁以上的人都已经打过一针了，所以我为此很高兴。是的，这太棒了，这正在慢慢发生，但希望在 2022 年我们能有机会面基。这就为我们的命名三部曲画上了句号。我们希望你今天过得愉快，我们下集见。
My partner just got her second vaccine yesterday. Oh, awesome. My grandfather and my dad are getting their second dose this week. My grandmother finally got hers. So now all of the people over 80 in my immediate family have gotten one so i'm happy about that yeah it's awesome it's uh it's happening slowly but hopefully 2022 we'll be able to meet up in person that brings our naming trilogy to an end we hope you have a great day and we'll see you in the next episode There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本集还没有评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。